what's the difference between start-up
mentality and corporate mentality
so recently I had an old friend of mine
that came up to me and asked me to
invest in a company that he wanted to
start he says here's the idea here's
what I want to do he set up the meeting
I didn't know what the meeting was about
and he says I'd like you to invest into
my company I said okay tell me what it
is I just wanted to hear that first it
says dot that got that done he says can
we raise the money I said money's never
the difficult thing to raise he says
well I'd like to have a $5,000 minimum
salary on a monthly basis and that would
be great I can help grow the company and
I said you know I want to talk to you
about a very simple concept about
business there is a big difference
between start-up mentality and corporate
mentality most people who are only in
the corporate world they don't
understand the startup mentality because
there's a completely from mindset in a
mentality but let me kind of give it to
you in the simplest way and what that
means you see I have babysat another kid
before in the past and maybe you have as
well the great thing about babysitting
is what you have the baby with you for
three hours you get paid 15 bucks an
hour you make $45 and then what do you
do at the end you had the baby over to
the parents right you Adam for three
hours and you hand it back that's
corporate mentality because I'm working
a few hours I make I leave I'm good
startup mentality it's your own baby and
you know what it is to have a newborn
baby for some of you got our parents we
have two babies under the age of two
years old and believe me our family is
purely startup right now because there
is no such thing as this they wake you
up three four times at night and they're
not only nine hours nine to five they're
24/7 is what they are so when you think
about the difference between start-up
mentality corporate mentality corporate
mentality is a limited number of hours
on what you do if you go out there say I
only work 9:00 to 5:00 and this is all I
want to do you're limited to how much
you can grow start-up mentality is 24/7
when you're running a business that you
really want to make it in bits and so
many people want to make it in business
but they really don't want to do the
things that it takes to run it and make
it in business
it's a ongoing thing when you're running
your own business now you may not be in
your business hours working with your
business but your mind is thinking about
how to grow your business just like your
kid may not be with you but as a parent
you are a parent for how many hours a
day 24/7 you're a parent right you're
always
thinking about your kids you know what
I'm talking about as a parent you can't
ever take that mind off so parenting is
purely startup mentality and for some
that say I don't know how to make a
business work if you're a parent I
promise you you know how to make a
business work because it's a similar
mindset of a startup mentality now for
some guys speak to some friends and this
I don't ever want to have kids I
understand it's a lot of work it's a lot
of work diapers are expensive asleep is
valuable for some and you are not going
to get a lot of it when you have newborn
babies but I'm going to tell you
something cure I'm gonna tell you
something here that's a little bit
different to think about there's a big
difference between a baby you're
babysitting hugs you and gives you kiss
versus your kid hugs you and gives you a
kiss and tells you mommy I love you
daddy I love you that's you know what I
mean it's priceless can't put a price
tag on it and there's a difference when
you just go in there just put a regular
price and you make your 15 bucks an hour
you know that's the cap there's a
difference between that right but
there's a difference also in business
when you run like a startup mentality
and the fruits of your labor are delayed
three five ten years and when they do
come oh they come when the late when the
fruits start coming to finance the start
can we start seeing the results but
you're not saying I got to make my
$3,000 or $5,000 a month corporate
mentality you are limited startup
mentality unlimited love forever with a
little bit of pain sometimes a lot of
pain but unlimited love now some of you
guys may say oh I have a job where you
tell me to quit my job no the people
that end up becoming seals of companies
they were employees but they ran their
job like a startup mentality so this is
not about jobs versus employees versus
entrepreneurs an employee could have a
start-up mentality and typically they
end up becoming the president and the
CEO of the company to see if wasn't a
company to see oh is it a company
because they don't have a set of hours
they're running with my message of the
week to him please be sure to share the
video if you like the content and
subscribe to this channel
you